FEMA administrator Brock long is leading
the federal government's response to
hurricane Michael he joins us from
Washington good morning good morning you
look at hurricane Michael and it is now
being described as an extremely
dangerous category four storm what is
your message to the millions in the
storm's path right now the message is
your time to evacuate is coming to a
rapid close here we're already seeing
rain bands in inundate many parts of the
Florida Panhandle and that means that
the water's starting to pile up along
the coast too and storm surge is what
we're most worried about that's why we
asked people to evacuate and we just
hope that people have heeded the
warnings and are getting out of harm's
way there's always somebody though Brock
that doesn't heed their warnings no
matter how many times you say it there's
always someone that says I got to stay
and protect my home what's your message
to those with to those people they've
made a decision they're not leaving well
you're putting your own life in danger
and more importantly you may be putting
others other lives in danger as well if
you if other people are staying with you
it's truly unfortunate I mean we saw
this in Florence you know we put the
warnings out and a large portion of
people died in their vehicles driving
over flooded out roads even though we're
saying turn around and don't drown so
this is just an unfortunate element that
comes with all of these storms and every
day you know the guys behind me at FEMA
we try to push the preparedness miche's
out and tell people why we asked them to
evacuate but unfortunately there's
always people that that seem to know
better than us and you're still working
on the aftermath of Florence just a few
weeks ago do you have enough resources
now to prepare and deal with Michael we
do right now we have nearly three
thousand people in the field from
Florida to North Carolina the UH the
unfortunate aspect about hurricane
Michael is is that this is going to not
only be a massive hit to the Florida
Panhandle and the coast but it's going
to maintain hurricane force winds
through the state of Georgia as well as
dump additional rainfall across the
Carolinas and with Florence you know the
Cape Fear River just started to recede
around October 8 October 9 but you know
we're forecasts they're forecasting
another three to six possibly eight
inches into the Cape Fear River Basin
which is truly unfortunate administrator
long there's the population
Florida's a little bit different than
other places older residents some of
them can't get out are there
preparations being made for nursing
homes and hospital facilities to deal
with power outages and those challenges
typically states you know mandate that
the privately owned nursing homes and
assisted care facilities have evacuation
plans in place hopefully those have been
executed but we're always on standby
with high water vehicles and search and
rescue vehicles if we get a last-minute
call for assistance but you know
typically Florida has their act together
you know Governor Scott and the Florida
Division of Emergency Management are
very well organized and stay on top of
those things so we hope we don't see too
many issues but if we do we're ready to
stand by and support as much as we can
well administrator long thank you so
much for spending some time with us this
morning we appreciate it thank you